meredith is solving the following
problem for homework two times the
quantity x plus four squared is equal to
two hundred and forty-two
she completes the problem as seen in the
steps below and they give us the steps
right over here when she gets to school
the next day her teacher tells her that
the answer is x equals 7 and x equals
negative 15. she only got x equals 7
here in what step did she make an error
so this first step right here and i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to figure this out on your own
before i work through it
so this first step let's see she got rid
of this 2 by dividing the left hand side
by 2 and she appropriately divided well
you can't just do that to one side you
have to do that to both sides in order
to hold this equality so she divided 242
by 2 as well so that is correct step 1
makes sense
and then she just wanted to instead of
this being an x plus 4 squared she
wanted to be an x plus 4. so she
attempted to take the square root of
both sides she said hey look the square
root of x plus 4 squared is x plus 4 and
the square root of 121 is 11.
and this is where she made a small but
very very very very important mistake
because if something squared is equal to
121 that means that something could be
the positive or negative square root of
121 this thing that we're squaring could
be positive 11 because positive 11
squared is 121 or x plus 4 right over
here could be negative 11 because
negative 11 squared is also 121. so this
right over here this should say x plus 4
is equal to the positive or negative
square root of 11. and so that's why she
missed out on one of the solutions right
over here so she messed up in step two
she should have taken the positive
or or positive and negative square root
so we got that right